[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde va de mieux en mieux
aujourd'hui et pour les années à venir
grâce à des solutions technologiques
mais aussi et peut-être surtout naturel
ce constat peut sembler une provocation
à l'heure où il semble de bon ton de
naviguer entre un pessimisme et
autoflagellation
pourtant ce constat est une réalité
indéniable et il est important de s'en
rendre compte important d'abord parce
que leur est trop gras avait les défis
trop importants pour laisser la place au
blâme et à la culpabilité
leur état l'action
à l'innovation cette innovation devra
être portée par un optimisme Chevilly au
corps pour contrer tous les vendeurs de
drames qui seront sur le chemin ce
constat est essentiel aussi car si vous
voulez dessiner un projet de société une
direction vous devez savoir
où vous êtes et d'où vous venez
sinon vous vous trompez nécessairement
sur la trajectoire
et cela peut être très grave
important enfin car ces visions
négatives
ne portent rien ne construisons rien et
ne résiste pas deux secondes surtout à
l'épreuve de la réalité
des faits
si je prends des statistiques
disponibles et non sujette à à
controverse de l'ONU
lors des siècles passés en la proportion
de personnes vivant dans l’extrême
pauvreté a été
de plus de 80%
depuis moins de deux siècles cette
proportion a chuté vertigineusement et
encore été divisé par deux
dans les 20 dernières années
pour atteindre moins de 9% aujourd'hui
de la population mondiale
il y a 50 ans le taux d'illettrisme
était de 80% dans le monde il est
aujourd'hui de moins de 15%. les
différences d'éducation entre les hommes
et les femmes
ont chuté vertigineusement eux aussi et
si nous continuons le combat comme il le
faut il disparaîtront dans les années à
venir
les progrès d'une science aujourd'hui
accessible à tous ont permis de vaincre
la polio la peste la variole et toutes
les maladies qui ont endeuillé endeuillé
et fait souffrir
nos ancêtres des siècles passés
les victimes par violence toutes formes
confondues et même par catastrophe
naturelle n'ont jamais été aussi basses
qu'au cours des décennies passées
pourquoi aucun journal ne fait ça une
sur le fait que depuis 20 ans tous les
jours nous avons sauvé de la famille 140
000 personnes tous les jours pourquoi
aucun journal ne fait ça une sur le fait
que chaque semaine
l'humanité
gagnant moyenne 2 à 5 jours d'espérance
de vie
pourquoi aucun média occidental
n'ose rappeler à tous que notre société
d'abondance de sécurité de santé et même
de loisirs ressemblent à s'y méprendre
au Paradis qui imaginait de nos ancêtres
des siècles passés après une vie de
souffrance et de labeur
si vous voulez bâtir un monde que vos
enfants puissent aimer il va falloir
apprendre à aimer ce qui peut l'être
dans le nôtre
par ailleurs c'est aussi rendre hommage
aux luttes mener avec succès par les
générations passées
j'ai grandi en Seine-Saint-Denis à
Montreuil parmi ceux des cités
je suis là aujourd'hui je sais ce que je
dois à ce magnifique progrès qui est
l'école de la République
au lieu de cela les journaux se couvrent
de crimes d'attentat et de guerre
qui pour grave qu'il soit ne représente
en aucun cas
l'évolution générale d'une société de
plus en plus sûre
bienveillante et empathique
regardez ici imaginez
que les crimes par violence sont
aujourd'hui tellement pas
qu'il représente quatre fois moins de
décès que ce causé par le diabète et
cette fois moins de décès que ce causé
par l'obésité
statistiquement vous avez donc plus à
craindre
d'une bouteille de soda que d'un
pistolet ou d'un couteau
et ce parallèle est intéressant pour
expliquer notre biais de perception qui
nous pousse à tout voir en noir et à
être obsédé par ses mauvaises nouvelles
chacun sait pourquoi nous sommes obsédés
par la Grèce et le sucre
pendant l'essentiel de notre évolution
de sapiens nous étions des chasseurs
cueilleurs courant la vaste pleine à la
recherche de ces nutriments rares alors
qu'on nous en trouvions nous nous
engavions
en prenant autant que possible pour
faire des réserves pour les jours voir
les semaines à venir
notre cerveau fonctionne toujours ainsi
même si pour l'essentiel d'entre nous il
faut avouer que nous courons moins
souvent la pleine
c'est ce qui fait que nous renonçons
à toutes nos résolutions quand nous
croisons une tablette de chocolat et
bien il en va exactement de même pour
les nouvelles anxiogènes
notre évolution a été guidée par une
incroyable capacité à identifier les
risques dans une nature sauvage et
inhospitalière
pour l'animal relativement faible que
nous sommes il était essentiel de
comprendre que tel serpent allait vous
tuer s'il allait s'il vous mordez que
telle herbe peut vous rendre malade et
que lorsque vous croisiez un lion le
mieux est sans doute de se cacher
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'arriver là
où nous sommes
et notre cerveau fonctionne toujours
ainsi même lit même si la société n'a
jamais été aussi sûr
d'ailleurs
en conséquence l'industrie médiatique
nous abreuve de mauvaises nouvelles avec
la même abondance sans doute cupide que
le fait l'industrie agroalimentaire pour
le sucre et la graisse
nous sommes donc tous
des infopèzes morbides
et c'est grave c'est grave car là où le
sucre et la graisse provoque l'abus en
tout cas provoque obésité diabète et
maladies cardiovasculaires
les mauvaises nouvelles
génèrent de l'anxiété de la dépression
et de la perte de lien social
loin d'être un électrochoc c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle vont inhiber l'action
créer de la colère et de la peur
celle-ci vont générer une forme
d'obscurantisme de populisme
qui favoriseront
la régression sociale puis scientifique
nous en avons de nombreux exemples
récents
encore plus graves
cette peur et cette colère et n'oublions
surtout pas la peur fracture la société
quand l'espoir rassemble
cette peur et cette colère vont créer ce
qu'on appelle un une prophétie
auto-réalisatrice
à force de
véhiculer cette perspective d'un avenir
cauchemardesque
nous en favorisions l'axe nous en
favorisons l'acceptabilité
et augmentant les chances et augmentons
les chances de voir cet avenir arriver
ainsi
moi par exemple je joue au tennis depuis
ma plus tendre enfance
je n'ai jamais été démenti sur un point
si je rentre sur le terrain en pensant
que je vais perdre cela arrive
inexorablement
si je rentre sur le terrain en me disant
que la partie va être très compliqué
mais que j'ai une chance réelle de
gagner
ça m'arrive du parvenir
pour bâtir un monde meilleur il va
falloir commencer par y croire
ensuite il va falloir identifier des
solutions si possible naturelle car tout
n'est pas technologique et la nature a
encore beaucoup beaucoup à nous
apprendre elles sont très nombreuses ces
ressources que nous avons oubliées
ignoré et qui peuvent répondre aux
grands défis de notre époque les lichens
les champignons les éponges de mer le
phytoplancton l'immense biodiversité de
la vie aquatique mais aussi les insectes
ou l'incroyable complexité de la vie
microbienne que nous commençons à peine
à comprendre
tous ces organismes depuis 4 milliards
d'années
ont dessiné l'histoire de la vie
sur terre et détiennent les clés de son
avenir
moi
j'ai découvert ma solution que je
voulais porter avec espoir
ne plus être à l'unisson des Cassandre
médiatiques j'ai découvert ça un peu par
hasard voilà quelques années
je travaillais dans l'agroalimentaire et
je me lamentais de ces systèmes dépassés
d'un côté laisser mourir de faim un
milliard de personnes
tandis que de l'autre contribuait
gravement à l'accélération des crises
climatiques et environnementales
l'explosion démographique en cours nous
laissait à ce simple choix devons-nous
accepter de laisser mourir de faim des
millions ou des milliards de personnes
en plus
ou continuer de détruire notre
environnement
et notre climat
triste perspective
et puis j'ai eu cette révélation
cette révélation que notre planète est
couvertes à 70% par des océans qui
aujourd'hui contribuent à moins de 2% de
notre alimentation cette révélation que
2% des océans cultivés de manière
régénérative suffirait à nourrir 12
milliards de personnes sans aucun besoin
de protéines végétales ou animales
terrestres
cette révélation que cette
océan de solution
reposée sur des organismes
les plus abondants au monde mais aussi
ignorer méprisé partout les algues
ces algues
4 milliards d'années d'existence de
compréhension de la résilience
nous sommes 10 000 fois moins
expérimentés qu'elle à la survie
elles ont tant à nous apprendre ces
algues surtout qui peuvent représenter
des ressources incroyables pour nourrir
de manière durable notre population mais
aussi nos animaux en favorisant leur
immunité leur bien-être en réduisant
leur méthane ces vagues qui peuvent
fournir des innovations de rupture dans
le domaine médical qui nous permettront
de vaincre encore plus de maladies ces
algues qui peuvent remplacer les
fertilisants qui polluentaires ces
plastiques qui polluent nos océans ces
algues surtout qui
recraient répare la biodiversité des
océans
c'est la plus grande du monde celle qui
est la source de tous ces algues les
nourrissent et leur fournissent en
habitat
ces algues qui poussent tellement vite
qu'elles absorbent plus de carbone que
n'importe quelle forêt terrestre et
peuvent donc répondre au défi du
réchauffement climatique ces algues qui
n'ont besoin que d'eau salée et de
soleil pour pousser et vont fournir des
ressources aux populations côtières où
la misère s'accumule de manière horrible
alors que les ressources de la pêche
décroissent et vont bientôt disparaître
tout n'est pas perdu
et depuis que j'ai commencé à soutenir
cette cause tout s'est enchaîné de
manière logique et incroyable
j'ai commencé par être recruté par l'ONU
qui m'a donné les moyens
de faciliter le développement de cette
nouvelle filière on m'a demandé d'écrire
un livre en suite
qui a connu un succès relatif mais qui
nous a tous surpris et qui est
aujourd'hui traduit dans de nombreuses
langues
on m'a invité dans beaucoup de médias à
expliquer pourquoi cette solution des
algues était notre cause à tous et
commencez dans notre assiette tous les
jours
tout cela a donné naissance à de
nombreux financements publics et privés
qui permettent le développement encore
émergent mais réel de cette filière si
pleine d'espoir pour notre planète et
pour notre santé
les algues ne suffiront pas
mais si nous apprenons un peu
l'austérité et faisons converger
l'ensemble de ces ressources naturelles
oubliées et inexplorées alors peut-être
et peut-être que nous verrons au fil de
ce voyage quelque chose d'encore plus
important
car depuis que j'ai commencé à défendre
cette cause des algues voici quelques
années la plus grande des leçons n'est
pas
ne tient pas dans les ressources presque
miraculeuses de ces organismes
la plus grande des leçons que je retiens
et cet éclat d'espoir et d'enthousiasme
que j'ai vu renaître dans les yeux de
mon auditoire
cette conscience que une histoire
positive bien racontée à tous et
scientifiquement fondés peuvent vraiment
faire la différence
et cet éclat d'enthousiasme je l'ai vu
surtout renaître
dans les yeux de cette jeunesse
il m'a invité ici ce soir dans cet
université à parler cette jeunesse qu'on
a bercé de nos angoisses qui n'a pas
connu l'insouciance de notre enfance à
nous cette jeunesse qui est plus
consciente que n'importe quel autre des
défis écologiques qui s'annoncent et
bien cet éclat d'enthousiasme que j'ai
pu voir naître dans leurs yeux il
s'apprête à embarquer pour une histoire
très différente de celle que nous on
leur a raconté
il s'apprête à renverser ses montagnes
de drame annoncées depuis des décennies
cet espoir là il peut vraiment tout
changer
alors il faudra bien plus que quelques
coups de raquette audacieux pour
remporter la partie mais nous avons
encore de nombreux atouts à jouer ce
combat sera le plus difficile et le plus
important que nous aurons amené
et si nous cherchons des solutions
innovantes naturelles et technologiques
et surtout si nous en partageons
l'espoir et l'optimisme sans nous
lamenter sans chercher des excuses ou
des coupables sans verser dans nos
travers
négatifs ou passés
alors ce combat pour un monde de progrès
ce combat pour un monde qui continue
d'aller de mieux en mieux
ce combat là je crois que grâce à vous
nous allons le gagner merci par avance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]